The search for an RSV vaccine has taken decades.
But tonight, Pfizer says new data for its experimental shot, given to pregnant women...
...early in the third trimester,...
...was 69% effective in preventing severe respiratory illnesses...
...in newborns in their first six months of life.
The company says it's even more effective in the first three months.
It's a real breakthrough.
I would say that people have been searching for a vaccine for nearly six decades,...
...at least five without success.
So, this is a major triumph for women and their babies.
Pfizer's data has not yet been peer reviewed.
The company says it plans to apply for vaccine approval before the end of this year.
But shots in arms may not come until next winter.
It's extremely frustrating.
Irene Aaron in Baltimore knows the stakes.
Two of her children with RSV have gone to the hospital in the past few weeks.
I think the toughest part is not being able to do much,...
...but just kind of wait and let it run its course.
As more hospitals brace for a triple threat of RSV, the flu,...
...and new Covid variants this winter,...
...Orange County, California has just declared a health emergency.
And another concern is emerging.
Across the U.S., some pharmacies are reporting shortages...
...of one of the most widely used antibiotics, liquid Amoxicillin.
It's commonly prescribed to treat ear infections, pneumonia, and bronchitis in children.
It's concerning because it's happening in a time of the year...
...where the demand is increasing.
It's not clear what's causing the shortage of the antibiotic...
...or how long it could last.